you know I have to ask you
how's your marriage
I think we need a break
what's the matter
I'm gonna have to pull over
Sun empty
is it the war it come in I know I've not
been around so much
I don't actually know what it is so you
don't know what's wrong we know what
happens when you're unfulfilled we've
been there
I don't feel anything anymore
looking for my wife you didn't see a
woman in here I don't know
Lisa Lisa
Lisa
[Applause]
here oh she's not she's with you weren't
you supposed to drop her off here
one minute she was there the next minute
she was gone did you have a fight is
that what this is
what's your emergency yeah I would like
to report a missing person my wife
I need the hammer footage from
surveillance camera's been busted a
couple weeks
I said the camera is not working
that's life what's going on here I got
no video here okay okay
thank you
who's that man
you ever had an affair
no I haven't had an affair does your
wife
a weird [ __ ]
step out of the vehicle for a minute
you pop in the trunk please
a simple guy
I don't have any special skills
no secret service no special forces but
if someone harms my wife
will be hell to be
[Music]